solitary confinement is when any
prisoner is kept in their cell for
roughly 23 hours a day seven days a week
with very few opportunities to leave
even that hour which is supposed to be
for rec time is often in just a slightly
larger cage or concrete room you're in a
cell as small as 6 by 8 feet which
people have described as roughly the
size of a small bathroom or walk-in
closet it's usually nothing but concrete
and steel you'll have your bunk you'll
have a toilet and sink maybe a shelf
that's about it
you're only human interaction is a
guards hand shovel food through a slot
in the door
some states can basically keep you in
solitary for your entire prison sentence
because they consider you a threat to
the prison population that can last
decades psychologists say solitary
confinement can cause or exacerbate a
mental illness studies suggest that
people with mental illness those that
are more moldable to the trauma of
isolation are even more likely to end up
there
but even people who are perfectly sane
unstable report really struggling inside
solitary and long after they get out a
prison might use solitary for both
trying to separate alleged gang members
and is discipline for a wide range of
infractions something as small as having
too many postage stamps or not making
your bed and once you're in there it can
be easy to stay even if you go into
solitary for maybe a 10-day sentence
while you're in there you may break
another rule those tickets can stack up
and you can end up there for years